how concerned is the aviation business
about all this Paul Briggs its joint
head of aviation at the international
law firm bird and Bernice with me in the
studio Paul let's start with that how
concerned is the world of aviation about
what it's this is obviously very bad
news not only for the individual
passenger for the airline but it just
makes the airline industry look bad just
like to pick up on some of the
statements that the counsel for the
individual said that he referred to the
airline industry bullying people and
giving a less than they deserve I think
that this has been a disaster for the
airline and a number of things have gone
wrong but I think that the airline
industry really values its clients its
customers and I think they've been
enormous changes made in recent years to
make sure that airlines that a customers
do get a good happy treatment from their
from their carrier but is there a big
difference between European airlines
moving Ryanair try and make itself more
friendly and and American Airlines here
you know I'm not gonna start criticizing
America now on scuzz that's not gonna
help me or anyone at all what I would
say is picking up on the positive side
of what you've said take Reiner so
Reiner is one of the airlines which has
led the development of low-cost carriers
around Europe now that has been good for
the European consumer so there was a
time when Michael O'Leary used to humor
us all and needs to be rather fabulous
with the way he'd say either you're not
paying a lot so what do you expect well
look at low-cost carriers now it's that
easy jess now attracts an enormous
amount of business traffic even reiner
is making an effort to be more cuddly
and more friendly to its passengers and
I take the example of jet2.com as its
its logo is friendly low fares and
there's a reason for that so even
low-cost carriers in Europe have learned
how to please their their passengers I
might say though the United logo is come
friend come fly the friendly skies I
mean there's nothing friendly about
dragging that plane okay so this is the
disaster at every level and a number of
things have gone wrong so I have to say
that we very rarely come across this
because normally if an airplane is
overbooked you don't put the past new
on the airplane is overbooking pulled
the key to this I mean if we got rid of
overbooking would we seafarers go okay
the answer to that is how much more do
you want to pay to travel so I haven't
got the statistics in front of me
because I had quite a busy day but a lot
of passengers do not turn up for their
flight so unless the airline over books
you'll be flying around in a half full
3/4 full airplane and you will be paying
more per flight so it's not really over
booking Airlines have to manage that
that's good airline business what's gone
wrong here is that the passengers got on
the airplane then it was made clear to
them that they were being asked to leave
not for another passenger to get on but
for a staff rotation so clearly that's
not great from a customer relations
perspective but also then the way it was
handled so how much do you think all
this is going to cost to settle I mean
that's what we talk about here is an
illegal settlement presumably it's going
to be a very big check isn't it well you
know that's a big ugly mess and I
haven't got any opinion on that at all
what I do have an opinion on is the way
that European airlines protect their
passengers so you may have heard of
regulation 261 generally in Europe
denied call denied boarding so in Europe
because of the way that the low cost
carrier market developed now if you are
denied boarding onto an aeroplane or if
your flight is more than three hours
later you're entitled to a whole load of
compensation we're a lot more protected
you're well not only are you well
protected in Europe but actually an
airline ends up as being the insurer of
last resort often for no cause of its
own thank you very much as poor breaks
there from That Bird and